[Music]
the dude abided once so why isn't he
abided again we're just dropping in to
see what condition his sequel is in
not only did Joel and Ethan Cohen write
and direct some of the most critically
acclaimed films of the 1990s and 2000s
but they made a lot of them quickly
after the release of The Big Lebowski in
1998 the duo churned out 11 movies over
the next 20 years however one thing
they've never done and might never do is
a sequel to any of their Works
especially The Big Lebowski it is worth
noting however that there was a
theoretical Barton thing follow-up they
kicked around called Old Fink so the
sequel is not entirely impossible just
unlikely
so what's the resistance here according
to the Toronto Star when asked about
another Big Lebowski movie at the 2013
Cannon Film Festival Joel Cohen told
reporters I just don't like sequels to
seemingly put a nail in that coffin
Ethan Cohen admitted I don't see it in
our future is this will not stand
further
than a proper starts on The Big Lebowski
sequel is the fact that Joel and Ethan
Cohen have entered a new phase of their
working relationship in 2021 Joel went
solo and directed the tragedy of Macbeth
Ethan followed suit making driveaway
dolls with his wife Trisha cook however
it was recently revealed that the cohens
haven't permanently ended their
cinematic partnership in the August 2023
issue of Empire magazine Ethan revealed
that he and Joel are working on a new
project together chances are almost zero
that it's a sequel to The Big Lebowski
but if the brothers are making movies
together again perhaps one day we might
get more bowling alley Adventures
needless to say Jeff Bridges is totally
down for The Big Lebowski too when
people ask about the possibility of a
follow-up film in May 2023 the legendary
actor replied oh God if the brothers
were involved I certainly would the
brothers they're mysterious and full of
surprises I don't think they'll make a
sequel but like I say they're surprising
so maybe they'll surprise me and make a
sequel but what about the rest of the
cast well in February 2011 Tara Reid who
played kidnapping victim bunny Lebowski
told Hollywood TV about all the future
projects she had lined up and said we'll
be doing American Pie four this year and
Big Lebowski two this year of course
there was one major problem with that
statement there was no such a Lebowski
sequel in development upon hearing this
a blindsided Ethan Cohen equipped to the
Austin American statesman I'm glad she's
working on it an employee of reads told
Entertainment Weekly that their boss was
likely confused by comments Jeff Bridges
made a few months earlier he had
publicly advocated for a new Lebowski
movie but it also admitted that such a
film wasn't actually in the works still
will read appears to be on board and she
embridges aren't the only ones who'd be
down to take another crack at their
kooky characters some Elliot who played
the stranger the Sarsaparilla drinking
the rater and passive participant in The
Big Lebowski would also very much like
to film a follower when asked by Variety
in 2017 it would be willing to make the
sequel Elliot replied I'm gonna hurt me
in 2014 some Cohen fans believed they
were going to get what they always
wanted in September of that year the
national report claimed that Jordan
Ethan Cohen had confirmed shooting would
begin shortly on a Big Lebowski sequel
Liverpool also included an alleged
statement from Ethan Cohen that read
we're thrilled to be coming back to film
a second part to this classic movie for
years we've been staying away from doing
this project but when we received this
new script and the cast fell into place
it was a no-brainer according to Snopes
the story spread fast on social media
and other far-reaching websites before
the general public realized it wasn't
true and considering how the coven
brothers almost exclusively penned the
movies they direct the parts about
receiving new script should have been a
dead giveaway as it turns out the
national report was a phone new site and
it even included a disclaimer alerting
readers to the fictitious nature of its
stories while there are no official
concepts for a true sequel to The Big
Lebowski this hasn't stopped interested
parties from speculating on the plot of
such a project including the dude
himself Lebowski star Jeff Bridges once
a Cohen's to pursue a film about his
character's Offspring he told Business
Insider in 2016 I'm hoping they make a
little Lebowski because it's all set up
I impregnated mod as the stranger says
there's a little Lebowski on the way you
know we really paid the room together my
owner officially sanctioned sequel to
The Big Lebowski has ever been greenlit
written produced or even approved by the
original film's creators the movie has
inspired some low-key and unconnected
spin-offs Jeff Lebowski drinks White
Russian cocktails of the matter of
course but in a 2019 Super Bowl
commercial for Stella Artois he tried
one of the company's beers and enjoyed
it Jeff Bridges reprise his role of the
dude for the bad and he even wore the
character's memorable costume of course
there's also a feature-length film set
in the world of The Big Lebowski a
little Indie flick titled the Jesus
rolls although the Cohen Brothers had
nothing to do with making it instead the
2019 film was written and directed by
actor John Turturro as a way to once
again portray his Lebowski character
convicted sex offender and Falmouth
Master bowler Jesus Quintana but Jesus
is the only connection to The Big
Lebowski as the film was otherwise about
the character's post-present release
crime spree and it actually borrows more
from the French film going places than
its Coen Brothers predecessor
foreign